Why is it that we as a
country have such a hard time
coming to terms with
our past and some
of the uglier chapters?
We think that saying
I'm sorry makes you weak.
And I think that's what has
to change in this country.
You can't actually
tell the truth
if you're not
willing to confront
the mistakes you've made.
If you go to South Africa, you
see a nation that is committed
to never forgetting apartheid.
There's an Apartheid Museum.
If you go to Rwanda, you see
a country that is determined
to not forget the genocide.
And if you go to
the genocide museum,
they actually have
human skulls in there--
that's just how powerfully
they want to express
their pain and anguish.
I was in Berlin a month ago.
And when you go to Berlin,
you can't go 100 meters
without seeing markers and
stones that have been placed
next to the homes
of Jewish families
that were abducted
during the Holocaust.
And the Germans want you to
go to that Holocaust Memorial,
because they want to
change their identity.
They haven't pretended that
there wasn't this thing
called the Holocaust.
But in America, we don't
talk about slavery.
We don't talk about lynching.
We don't talk about segregation.
And because of
that, we don't have
a healthy relationship with one
another on the topic of race.
Why are memorials,
statues, schools, highways--
why is this symbolism
so important?
There are some people, I think,
who think, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
What's the big deal?
When we honor
people that tried
to defend and
perpetuate slavery,
we create that same
kind of dissonance.
We cannot legitimize slavery.
We can not legitimize lynching.
We cannot honor segregation
and racial hierarchy.
We just can't do it and recover.
And that's the reason
why those statues matter.
Those street names matter.
Those statues and
schools and highways
send an incredibly
powerful symbol that is
really almost hard to describe.
It is hard to describe.
And the history around them
makes that symbol even more
disruptive, even more painful.
Because these monuments
and memorials were largely
erected to signal triumph
of a narrative war.
The North won the Civil
War, but the South
won the narrative war.
They won the battle
of never having
to apologize for the
violence and destruction,
for having enslaved people.
It was designed to
communicate to black people
that racial hierarchy,
white supremacy will
still be the law of the land.
And I don't think
we've appreciated
the harm, the psychic harm
of what these symbols can do.
And not just to
African-Americans and people
of color, to all of us.
Because when we are
forced, in this region,
to make ourselves proud
of things that are not
worthy of pride,
to make ourselves
proud of things that
should really induce shame,
we corrupt ourselves.
We really do.
Should statues of Robert
E. Lee and Jefferson
Davis and other
Confederate heroes
be removed, in your view?
I wouldn't remove
them because we all
get closer to recognizing
that they should have never
been put up in the first place.
I want to get to the point
where we accept and acknowledge
that we're celebrating
things that we
shouldn't be celebrating.
We should actually name some
streets after white Southerners
who tried to end slavery.
We can name streets and
schools after white Southerners
who tried to stop lynching.
And then we could
all be proud of that.
And it would do something
that these symbols don't do,
which is that it could
bring people together.
How do you convince people
who feel these statues are so
associated with their
personal stories
that they don't
want let that go?
My interest in talking
about our history
is to not punish America
for this history.
I want to liberate us.
And there is a way to
be a white southerner
and proud of who you
are and acknowledge
the pain of this past.
That's what
restoration is about.
reconciliation is about.
Native Americans have to
watch all this unfolding
and think, when are people
going to accept and acknowledge
what happened to us?
You can't live in a community
like Montgomery, Alabama
without being mindful
that the Creek Indian
Nation were forced to cede
21 million acres of land
to create this space.
And then they were forced on
a trail of tears to the west.
Their burial grounds,
their sacred spaces
were destroyed to build hotels
and banks so that black people
could then be enslaved.
And that story of the
Native American genocide
is a story that we
also have to confront.
We have to talk about that.
We have to deal with that.
Are you optimistic
we're at a moment in time
that we can come to
terms with the past?
I'm optimistic because
maybe we're in a moment where
the silence is breaking down.
And if we can break
down the silence,
I have no doubt that something
beautiful can emerge.
[music playing]